hey guys this next clip was made
possible by news voice which is a
democratized news app created to fight
back against the filter bubbles caused
by corporate media download for free
from news voice calm slash Pakman or
click the link under this video the
fallout from Bob Woodward's book about
the Trump White House continues and
today I want to focus in on comments
from Gary Cohn who's a former economic
adviser of Donald Trump's who says
according to Bob Woodward's book this is
pretty full on that Donald Trump has the
IQ of an inbred tanning bed which is
really a nice comedic touch because just
saying he has the IQ of a tanning bed is
sort of funny and it maybe is a
connection to Donald Trump's fake
tanning which he is so known for but
adding the touch about the inbred
tanning bed really puts it over the top
for me and this is now not merely
anecdotal that's really the story for me
the people who stopped working for
Donald Trump and don't have some
personal interest in not disparaging him
sometimes they're party to
non-disclosure agreements that they
choose to abide by although sometimes
they choose to ignore them or those who
are not hired to be Trump apologists so
Cory Lewandowski Trump's former campaign
manager sort of famously left Trump's
World Organization campaign
administration whatever and went on CNN
but he was hired as the Trump guy so he
wasn't going to go on and say bad things
those who just leave and say what's on
their minds seem to say really bad
things about Donald Trump including that
the reality is way worse than what the
public knows and that's exactly what
Gary Cohn who was part of the Goldman
Sachs wing of the Trump administration
is saying according to Bob Woodward's
new book Cohn was the director of the
National Economic Council for Trump for
a little while and he was reportedly
stunned by how ignorant Trump was
starting from day one
Trump has according to
koan and from what we know a pretty
fundamental misunderstanding of basic
economics and even of how money works
remember that phone call he made to one
of his national security advisors
Michael Flynn to ask him about whether
the dollar going up versus down was good
for the United States and Gary cones
anecdotes about Trump's money knowledge
are truly amazing Kohn told according to
Bob Woodward Kohn told Trump that the
Fed was probably going to be increasing
interest rates during Donald Trump's
first term and Trump allegedly said we
should just go borrow a lot of money
hold the money and then sell the money
for more and we will make money and Cohn
explained to him no no if we borrow
money that increases the deficit and you
said you wanted to get rid of the
deficit to which Trump responded just
run the presses print money according to
Bob Woodward so the trend is Trump is
ignorant his first Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson called him a [ __ ]
defense secretary Jim mattis according
to Bob Woodward told close associates
that Trump quote had the understanding
of a fifth or sixth grader former White
House deputy chief of staff Katie Walsh
reportedly said that working with Trump
was quote like trying to figure out what
a child wants I don't even know that I
agree because you can usually figure out
what the child wants it doesn't seem to
be clear what Trump wants and Scott
Pruett the EPA director said in not so
many words that Trump has effectively no
understanding whatsoever of both the
Constitution and the rule of law Pruitt
one of the most corrupt and vile members
of trumps administration even sees the
absurdity of what he's dealing with with
Donald Trump and now you have Gary cone
saying that Trump has the IQ of an
inbred tanning bed there are two kind of
parallel levels of debate or discussion
taking place right now on the right
within the right your's
starting to see some people engage in a
debate with trumpets about whether Trump
truly is or isn't qualified to be
president that's actually kind of a win
like just the fact that we're seeing
some Republicans say ok I Hillary's a
disaster I hate Hillary she's evil she
should be locked up whatever but Trump
may not be qualified to be President but
I'm still a Republican and I want a
Republican to be president the left is
beyond that we're now mostly exploring
on the left whether Trump is qualified
to I don't know run a car wash and I
don't want to insult car wash owners I
think the answer is clearly no Trump's
not even qualified to run a car wash and
car wash owners likely are more
qualified than Trump to be president
they probably have some basic
understanding of how money works
Breaking Bad I guess would be one
example of that but the this is
alternate universes we're seeing this
fork this divergence where on the right
were desperate to see even just a few
introspective critical comments about
listen maybe this guy shouldn't be
president whereas on the Left we're
saying this is a crisis of monumental
proportions